[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
[Applause]
how long do we have
seven days
[Music]
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here 7000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
[Music]
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
[Music]
[Applause]
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
you